قبل اكثر من 40 سنه
عرضوا لاول مره مسلسل عدنان ولينا
[موسيقى]
اندلعت الحرب العالميه الثالثه عام 2008
ولا شفنا التقنيات هذه لكن اللي صار شيء
ثوري اكثر شيء
عدنان ولينا ولا باقي افلام الخيال العلم
تقنيه بتغير طريقه عيش البشريه
هذا التقنيه المفترض تخلينا نعيش في عالم
مثالي
عالم كلنا اجسامنا في صحيه ورياضيه بدون
حتى ما نروح النادي بدون حتى ما تجاهد
نفسك على قطع الاكل اللي تحبه عالم نقدر
نختار في شكل عيان كثافه شعرهم لون عيونهم
عالم مافي امراض وراثيه ولا ايه زملائه
تنتقل بين البشر ولا سرطان يقتل فوق تسعه
مليون انسان سنويا حول العالم
[موسيقى]
السؤال من 2008 الى الحين ايش اللي مانعنا
من استخدام هذه التقنيه
عشان نفهم وش التقنيه خلونا نرجع للوراء
10,000 سنه
لما الانسان كان يعيش بشكل بدائي
الحضارات لم تتشكل بعد والعلوم جميعها في
بدايتها حتى وسائل العيش كانت بشكل بسيط
وبدائي مثل الزراعه وتربيه الماشي من هذاك
الوقت والانسان عارف ان فيه صفات تنتقل من
الوالدين للابناء بعد التزاوج ومن الممكن
ان الانسان يحدد هذه الصفات اذا اختار
الاب والام بشكل صحيح
وعشان كده صاروا يختارون الخير والفرس
المناسب عشان ينتجون خيول اجمل او ابقار
تدر حليب اكثر
ما كان الانسان يعرف ليش وكيف تنتقل هذه
الصفات ولكن في القرن الماضي
[موسيقى]
وتسلسل مكون من اربع حروف
يعني لو كاتب يشتغل ثمان ساعات في اليوم
بس مشغول يكتب هذه الحروف تاخذ منه اكثر
من 50 سنه عشان يخلصها لما عرفوا العلماء
ان لجين هو المسؤول الاول والاخير عن كل
هذه الاشياء
كان الهاجس عندهم دائما هل نقدر نتحكم
ونغير بصفات المخلوقات الحيه اننا نعيد
كتابه هذا الجيد من هذا المنطلق بدات
التجارب
[موسيقى]
في عام 1982 جربنا التعديل الجيني على
البكتيريا ضبط وقدرنا ننتج الانسولين
استخدام الانسولين كانوا ينتج بتعديل جيني
على البكتيريا وبعدين ياخذ الانسولين هذا
ويحقلون البشر هذا كان بدايه علاج السكر
وجربنا التعديل الجيني عن النباتات
الذره عدلت جينيه حتى تقاوم من المبيدات
بشكل افضل وتتحمد درجات الحراره المختلفه
وجربناها الحيوان
وضبط كثير من سمك السلمون اليوم معدل
جينيا عشان ينمو بشكل اسرع
[موسيقى]
وعلى الانسان هنا كانت المشكله كل تقنيات
التعديل الجيني المتوفره وقتها كانت خطيره
وغير دقيقه للتجارب على البشر
كنا نعرف الجينات وترتيبها بس ما نعرف كيف
نغير فيها بشكل امن وعملي
ولكن البكتيريا
كانت تعرف
[موسيقى]
بين البكتيريا والفيروسات حرب دائمه ومع
الوقت
[موسيقى]
فيسبوك
اكتشفنا اننا نقدر نختار جين مسؤول عن مرض
معين مثلا ونعطيه البكتيريا وهي بنظامها
الدفاعي كرسبر تقص الجين بالكامل ما يصير
موجود في جسمك ولا ينتقل لعيالك
[موسيقى]
زي الضمور العضلي مثلا
هذا واو جهاز رهيب انا مره يعني بس في
تغيير كبير بالنسبه لمرض الضمور يعني هي
من الحالات المعدله جنين
تصل دقه عمل 90%
وعلشان نستوعب فخامه هذه الدقه
نسبه النجاح هذه اعلى من كثير من العمليات
الجراحيه
بكده كريسبر حل المشكلتين اللي كانت تواجه
التعديل الجيني صار دقيق
رخيص يعني لو يظبط كريسبر مثل ما هو قادر
عليه يمكن تقفل المستشفيات ما رح يكون في
شيء اسمه مرض في المجتمع
كريسبر كتقنيه بحته قد تكون الحل
المستقبلي لكثير من مشاكل البشريه ولكن
في عام 2018 في بحث صيني صدم العالم
لما اعلن في مؤتمر للتعديل الجيني انه
عدله لاول مره على جينات اجنه في الاشهر
الاولى من
الحمللاقيات الا وتحدث تجريما لهذا الشخص
قالوا فيه ان فعله وحشي غير مسؤول وشنيع
وسجن في الصين مع انه والد الجنين كان
يحمل جين لمرض الايدز وكان الهدف من
التعديل هو ازاله جين العيد لكن العقاب
الشديد
الجيني على الخلايا الجسديه مسموح جزئيا
تطبيق على الانسان في كثير من دول العالم
ولكن
ممنوع تماما في اكثر من 40 دوله انك تعدل
على الخلايا التناسليه
والجيل الثاني هي ما تسمى الخلايا الجيم
اللي هي الخلايا التناسليه
لان التعديل الجيني على الاجنه والبويضات
والحيوانات المنويه بينتج عنا تعديل دائم
ومستمر ومتوارث والسيطر عليه بتكون اصعب
تذكر 90% نسبه النجاح الكرسبر هذه صحيح
ولكن المشكله كلها موجوده في العاشره
بالمئه نسبه الفشل هذه الممكنه يعني مثل
لما تقول 10% من رحلات الطيران
[موسيقى]
من الداخل
المسبب للسرطان هو نفس الجين الخاص بالنظر
مثلا
ولكن بالرغم من كل المشاكل والتحديات الا
ان المصابين بامراض علاج الوحيد وكريسبر
مستعدين للمخاطره كلها
اما السبب الثاني للمنع هو صعوب التحديد
ما يعالج بالتعديل الجيني
اذا خلصنا من المشاكل اللي هي تدعم الحياه
حيخشوه على التجميل هذا اكيد كريسبر ممكن
يسمح لك باختيار الشكل اللي تبيه الطفله
انا ممكن اغير شخصيه الشخص اذا غيرت
الجينات لها علاقه بالشخصيه لها علاقه
بالذكاء وهذا ما يعرف
بتصميم الاطفال
الانسان المثالي من وجهه النظر
النازيه في هذاك الفته هو الشخص المقتول
القوي الطويل
ابو شعر اصفر وعيون عيون زرق فكانوا
يجيبوا الاشخاص هذول ويسوي لهم برامج
تزاوج مش زواج تزاوج مع سيدات يحمل نفس
المواصفات بحيث انه يكون فيه جيل مهجن
بحيث انه يركز انه انا ابغى المجتمع يكون
بهذه الكيفيه
نفس الفكره اللي يجر فيها الانتخاب العرقي
النازي
الانتخاب الجيني ليس الاسباب اخرى والله
ولد يكون اسرع ولد اقوى ولد اطول ولد اعظم
ولد اذكى ولد ومرتفع هذه كلها بتخلي
المجتمع في النهايه تتميز الى تصورات
قبليه لما هي المثاليه
هذا هو السؤال ولو اتفقنا وشرعت الانظمه
التعديل الجيني للعلاج دون التجميد ايش
اللي فرق بينهم هل ازاله السمنه علاج
كثير من شركات التامين تعتبر التكميم جزء
من التجميل ولو سمحت للتعديل الجيني بان
يكون متاح للجميع باساليب بسيطه هل بتعتبر
متلازمه داون مرض يجب علاجه
هل بتسمح للتعديل الجيني ان يمحو متلازمه
داون الوجود مثلا بالرغم من اللي فيهم
داون وهاليه
لذلك السبب التحديد في الاخلاقيات حاجه
اسمها سلوبري سلوب او المنزلق اذا سمحت
للفكره لن تستطيع ان يسيطر عليها
يعني الانحراف ترى يبدا درجه واحده ثم
يصبح كيلو مترات بين النقطتين اليوم تقنيه
تعدل على الجيم الجيم اللي يعتبر اصغر من
حجم النمله
اربعه مليون مره
[موسيقى]
ولكن الحذر في تعديل شيء اساسي وجوهري حمض
النووي للانسان
سلالاتنا البشريه هذا الحذر واللي بيضمن
لنا نحن نستخدم هذا التقنيه دون ان نقع في
حفره التعديل الجديد
[موسيقى]